Adam Levine is teaming up with Grammy  nominee Charlie puth et Kim exclusively  revealed charlie is a mentor for teen  Adam on the voice  he's mega-talented and he's my friend  he's super cool and I love him I would  say all the same things too  I hope so no I genuinely mean that yeah  yep Adam and Charlie have a legit  bromance  sorry play they work out together swap  clothes and have slumber parties this  sweatshirt actually that I have it bears  I wore yesterday it's great sweatshirt  what is this very expensive if you want  it back you can have it pack your stuff  is at my house so and half your stuff is  at my house sleepovers everything  Charlie's not new to the voice in 2016  he was a mentor for Alicia Keys but  season 16 marks a first for another one  of Adams buddies John Legend who joins  Adam Blake and Kelly as coach greatest  easiest guy to get along with all the  planet and absolute greatest hope he  wins if it's not if it's not me you know  I hope it's  [Music]